you've got to
believe in yourself
and be stronger than anybody
else you gotta keep your head up
[Music]
las vegas most celebrated entertainers
and philanthropists are once again
joining forces against
neurofibromatosis and you can be a part
of this incredible event i'm joined by
jeff and melody lebo the founders of the
nf hope concert and the inspiration
behind the 11th annual event emma good
good afternoon thanks for coming in you
guys thank you emily came straight from
school it's a busy day for you
and you truly are the inspiration tell
us tell us about this event and and how
this came to be well emma has a
neurological disorder called
neurofibromatosis or nf and soon after
she was diagnosed in 2010
uh we were on the phone with an
executive director of one of the
national charities and she asked what we
could do and out of that little question
came
this idea a kind of gershwin-esque idea
that turned into a concert and now we're
11 years in and over a million dollars
raised melody tell me a little bit about
nf and and how you found out that emma
had it and what what does that entail
so nf known as neurofiber mitosis causes
tumors to grow on any nerve in the body
at any time and from there you know a
range of things can happen people lose
their hearing their sight things like
that
emma has several tumors in her body but
she was diagnosed at nine months old
just from three markers she had a brain
scan that showed something
she had some freckling and she had cafe
lace spots um that are typical of nf
kids
so so you guys decided to put this event
together and what what an incredible
thing las vegas is such a great city
don't you absolutely and you're one of
our great entertainers here tell us a
little bit about the show who's going to
be performing what are you guys going to
be doing you know the cool thing is
we're at the smith center myron's at the
smithsonian for the second time and
because of such a great intimate space
we're just highlighting local talent so
we've got ashley fuller and jason allen
and and lou gazera from american idol
who's now a headliner here and our
friend nicole pryor from uh from phantom
and we even do a song that emma chooses
for us every year um it's gonna be it's
it's just a great day of aft
entertainment all to raise money and
awareness for nf now it may be a
surprise emma but do you have the song
all ready to go do you know what it's
going to be yeah can you say it or do
you want to keep it a surprise for
people to go oh
i want to keep it up
you know what an inspiring girl you are
and how strong you are how how have you
been how have you been feeling and what
does an event like this mean to you
um good and now that it's back in person
i'm excited that i get to see more than
just someone's face and that some of my
friends get to come that's nice i think
we're all excited about that to be
honest now how do people get tickets to
this exciting event uh the easiest way
is to go to the smith center and go to
thesmithcenter.com
hope um and then there's we also have an
auction so if you just go to nfhope.org
which is our main website you can get
your tickets you can get links to the
auction the auction just opened today
and apparently there's half of the items
already have bids on them so oh we'd
love it i'm gonna put you on the spot
can you get a little something
i tell you what at sunday at one o'clock
i will be ready for you and i will sing
whatever you like
thank you guys so much for taking the
time we really appreciate it the